top secret jfk assassination files are
finally released lee harvey oswald was
in contact with a member of a kgb two
months ago two months before shooting
and anonymous phone calls said russia
was behind it uh trove of 1500 documents
revealed this is on page
uh five uh biden said he wanted to do
this they finally did it more than
fifteen hundred percent accounts
remember the public comments you're
going to see 100 okay they include memos
detailing anonymous phone calls from a
u.s embassy in cabrera in cambra
australia a year before the shooting
where the caller said the soviet
government was plotting to kill kennedy
and details of oswald's meeting with a
kgb agent at soviet embassy in mexico
city two months before the shooting
another call was placed on november 24th
two days before the shooting claiming
the russians were behind it earlier this
year robert f kennedy jfk's nephew which
i'm about to do debate with him in the
next two weeks with him and somebody
that he just wrote a book about fauci
and it's not the nicest book about
fashion it's amazing yeah you read it
part of it i started a good friend of
mine turned me onto it who read it and
he told me all about it unbelievable
yeah we're doing it he's he's debating
somebody over the topic in the next
cheryl hines husband you know from curb
your enthusiasm yeah okay you've talked
to rfk before let me finish this time
let me finish this i'm gonna go so jfk's
nephew assumed that some of the files
would remain secret until next year how
the hell is it
58 years later and what in the world
would justify not releasing these
documents rfk said by the way these are
not all the files some of the files are
going to release next year and some of
them we may never find out about do you
think tom because i know you followed
this story you're somebody that's also
curious about this type you and i've
talked about this many times do you
think we're going to learn anything new
no i don't think so um there was the
speculation that um
you know that the russians were involved
that the you know that the cubans were
involved that felt betrayed by the bay
of pigs that the teamsters were involved
that sam giacono was involved and what i
find interesting here is they're all
pointing back to oswald which points
back to the single gunman theory which
is the one thing that every scientific
analysis of all the the echo and
everything in the tapes and clint hill
who you spoke to yep um
and the the last uh she i think is the
last living person that was in the first
two cars so no you're saying nothing is
anybody thinking anything new is going
to come through
nothing at all they'll never reveal the
stuff that actually tells you what
happened because somebody has to know do
you have a crazy theory on what you
think happened like 10 seconds what do
you think happened two options
internally mafia because the dad joe or
russia has to be involved what do you
think danielle i'm i'm with i'm with my
daddy was a bootlegger yeah
you know here's the thing how does a
secret like that stay a secret i mean
you i know people that we're when i go
places people tell me things i don't
know what it is you know people just
open up i learn who's sleeping with like
a priest they just feel comfortable
telling me things wow and i just
powerful i i don't know what it is maybe
it's my nice guy vibe or something but
how do people keep secrets like this how
does not one person reveal what happened
how do we not know how is it even
possible someone has to know and it sure
is the heck isn't one gunman there's
just no way it's impossible i mean if
you go to the jfk you know the site
where and you go to the building there's
just no way it's impossible they play
the tape and they show you fi four
echoes and then why was it so important
to kill him the next day i mean there's
just this is so fascinating i wish we
could learn there's a there's a lot of
stuff there i know
i interviewed jack barski two weeks ago
his interview came out yesterday jack
barski was a former kgb member from
germany he got recruited went to russia
they trained him and then he came out he
did espionage he did everything
so i showed him a video of uh
yuri besmanov if you've ever seen yuri
besmanov's interview before it's pretty
sick where he's talking about the whole
subversion and what they do and how they
train and how russia's trying to take
over u.s by getting their philosophies
of marxism and universities and
professors and teachers and get the
youth and eventually like today's modern
day of uc berkeley it's what they
essentially were talking about and
they've been successful
so i asked them all these other things
about the kgbs i was kgb involvement no
let me tell you what we did the kgb
number one
j edgar hoover was never a cross-dresser
we planted that well done he says he was
never a cross-dresser we told him and
threatened them that we're gonna do that
you know what else the eighth scandal
that was us we made that eighth scandal
in america we did that i'm like dude i
think you're gaslighting me right now
but anyways no one's going to know it's
a story
it's it's another great opportunity
right now for someone in hollywood
steven spielberg to make a jfk movie
right now
change the angle
and and bring the mob and you know maybe
ty you know godfather four coming out
with jfk's assassination link to it who
knows let me ask you a question do you
think the the immediate kennedy family
knows what happened
maria you know just maria
did a jackie know
is is it knowledge that's common at
least
is known as one of the greatest
environmental attorneys america's ever
had okay that's what rfk's reputation is
right
in the environmental attorney side he is
the best right
when he and i spoke the first time i
interviewed him i brought up the whole
jfk assassination conversation this is a
guy that explained it in such an
eloquent way that to him he spent his
entire lifetime trying to find out what
the hell happened because it wasn't just
his uncle it was also his father it's
emotional to this guy so i guarantee you
they know more than you and i think uh
they know i i i buy that that i buy yeah
i think i think they know i think they
know um maybe we'll bring rfk what's
really interesting about conspiracies
and history what's that right so the mob
always thinks a conspiracy is bigger and
there's more angles to it
but the
when you take a look at the the mafia
and the conspiracy of kills around the
families
conspiracies only stay quiet long term
if there's a small group of people and
then what you always look for is the
second kill
and so when you take a look at what
happened with kennedy if oswald was one
of the gunman apparently he was then you
look at the second kill well that was
oswald and so a small group of people
that then offs some of the people that
were executing it that's how the
conspiracies work and that's how they
stay secret so
when you
look at things long term
if it's a big giant conspiracy
you know it always leaks out and the
truth kind of comes around when it's a
small conspiracy and you have the second
and the third kills then it stays quiet
so you're better off not knowing because
you might be dead no no no no i mean
like oswald plus who else
was who was the guy there's one guy i
don't trust here's the one guy i don't
trust the one guy that i always just no
matter what i read i just don't get a
good feel about the guy is lyndon
johnson i just don't trust that yeah
nothing about that guy do i trust if you
read up his legacy the way he was wired
who he was he hated kennedy when kennedy
called him to be the vp he's like who
the hell do you think you are i'm
supposed to call you i'm the candidate
you don't call me and tell me to be the
vp i call you and tell you do you want
to be my vp i mean lyndon
that was his fastest way to being a
president
who's a pragmatist who knows i mean i'm
not telling you he did it all i'm
telling you is if he was that motivated
to be a president strategically he got
it done okay and his mistress had some
stories to say about it but
you're right in katherine graham's
biography who who used to be the
publisher of the washington
washington post she tells all the bloody
stories about the behind closed door and
lyndon johnson and how he he and jfk he
did he hated jfk
yeah and her husband was in the room 91
hours after the assassination lyndon
johnson started the vietnam war
after the french advisers had screwed up
and lit the tinderbox
i mean you just look at things like that
and it's it's a nasty nasty guy so
here's here's one thing
i think about
any president that was ever assassinated
or character assassinated typically
scare the hell out of the establishment
the establishment likes to pick who
becomes the next president the
establishment doesn't like you to pick
who becomes the next president the
establishment likes to pick who becomes
the next president as long as it's
within the crew of who we are okay cool
we're going to be fine because we'll
still have our card we'll still have our
parties we'll still have the country
club feeling all that other stuff you
bring one of these guys that lincoln out
of nowhere comes in or you get a
freaking uh you know reagan who goes
from hollywood and comes in and you were
fighting communist and you want to come
in and be the president what are you
talking about you talking about john f
kennedy and your father who is joseph
kennedy we don't like people like you
trump we don't like people like trump so
um yeah i don't know i i don't know if
if the establishment likes people like
lincoln kennedy reagan or trump they're
not big fans of them not at all this is
this is why we ought to be very grateful
to having a person like biden right now
in the white house
you know because you know it's just you
found a positive from him that's great
for biden it's the i've been reading a
lot of norman vincent
break we've gone from clinically insane
to medically dead give me a break
danielle danielle but you didn't support
the alternative
what alternative when the author said it
happened a year ago you didn't support
the alternative you have two choices
two choices between clinically insane
and medically dead yeah so so yo so i'm
proud to be an american
well what i'm saying to you is even a
year ago who who was our options we had
two of them yeah you had a trump and a
biden i know you did and they were both
democrats
so you see you see trump as a democrat a
new york democrat who gave to both of
kamala's campaigns and they've got
kamala you know locked in it
in the basement somewhere by the way
there is a precedent you know we were
talking earlier about biden being
replaced
we forget that spiro agne was replaced
during nixon's term so there's a
precedent for taking your vice president
out
just saying
well if it's this bad after one year
agnew was replaced for the equivalent of
a parking ticket nowadays oh true and
then eight months later kennedy was uh
uh nixon was out of office
and then they put gerald ford in so is
it a form of blaming somebody else it's
like shifting blame is that kind of what
you're thinking
i i
from everything that i've heard
you can't even put biden and harris in
the same room together
he actually wakes up and gets angry
enough that he's like actually got a
pulse
huh that actually could be a good thing
though and no like that that can get
maybe they should put her in the room
right before right before good morning
it keeps them alive
they need to put her in the room right
before he goes up to the podium for the
press conference because it'll be like
oh
now we can do the conspiracy loop spro
agno gone
gerald ford becomes the vice president
gerald forbes was on the warren
commission the warrant commission
investigated the kennedy assassination
general kennedy cheated
nixon gerald ford was a complete badass
i'm i'm going to stand up for gerald
ford here he was a military hero he was
a bad ass football player at michigan
yeah i mean two seasons undefeated
gerald ford was an amazing screwed up
tom amazing president okay you guys went
from sisters to now enemies in 30
minutes
let me change the story american let me
change the story gerald ford's a career
at the uh as a running back
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]